c'est l'histoire d'un couple ça fait 45
ans qui sont mariés ils veulent fêter
leur 45e année de mariage il invite au
restaurant et lui dit écoute ma chérie
maintenant ça fait 45 ans dis-moi les
vérités est-ce que tu m'as déjà trompé
sa femme elle le regarde et d'écoute je
te rappelle la maison qu'on a acheté et
dit oui il fallait un crédit oui bon le
crédit il a été refusé et une semaine
après il a été accepté
voilà j'ai couché avec le banquier le
gars il la regarde il dit c'était la
seule fois il dit non
tu t'es fait virer de ton travail et dis
oui et la semaine d'après il t'a
embauché ton patron et dit oui bah parce
que j'ai vu le patron puis bon il dit
bon c'est pas grave tu as couché pour la
bonne cause il dit c'est tout il dit non
rappelle
pendant les élections il fallait censé
qu'on le voit
[Applaudissements]